luego de esta reunión que se prolongó
durante tres horas en el Palacio de
Miraflores y que fue convocada a última
hora se emitió un comunicado conjunto en
el que se ratifica la postura del
gobierno de Nicolás maduro de respaldar
al gobierno de Colombia en La Búsqueda
del cc al fuego bilateral y la paz total
con la guerrilla del eln esto ocurre
pocos días después del impase entre el
gobierno de Gustavo Petro y la guerrilla
luego que el propio presidente anunciara
públicamente un cese al fuego bilateral
que se prolongaría durante seis meses y
tres días después el propio eln lo
desmintiera llamó la atención que
avanzaba esta reunión y minutos antes de
que culminara llegó al palacio de
Miraflores el general César Martínez
quien ha sido el representante de
Nicolás maduro ante los diálogos de paz
en el comunicado también se habla de
avances en materia comercial en la
reapertura de los puentes fronterizos no
hubo declaraciones a la prensa tras el
encuentro por el contrario mucho
hermetismo estuvieron presentes por
parte del gobierno colombiano el
canciller Álvaro Leiva el embajador de
Colombia en Unidos Luis Murillo y el
embajador de Colombia en Venezuela
Armando Benedetti así como el ministro
de comercio por parte del gobierno de
Nicolás maduro estuvieron presentes la
primera damacilia flores la
vicepresidenta delsy Rodríguez y el
recién designado canciller de Venezuela
y van Gil quien previamente sostuvo un
encuentro con Armando Benedetti
posterior al encuentro en Miraflores el
presidente Gustavo Petro fue recibido
por Armando Benedetti en su residencia
se espera que el mandatario colombiano
viaje este 8 de enero a Chile para un
encuentro bilateral con su homólogo
Gabriel boric